[موسيقى]
سجل بريطاني روسي بعد ان كشفت لندن انها
ستزود كييف بقضاء فخارقه للدروع
بهيورانيوم منظف الى جانب الشحنه دبابات
تشالنج الاثنين تقول بريطانيا انه مكون
معتاد ولا علاقه له بالاسلحه النوويه
وتتهم موسكو بالتضليل لكن هذه الاخيره
حذرت ان ذلك سيعد استخدام للقنابل النوويه
القذره حيث قال الرئيس الروسي ان بلاده
ستضطر الى الرد اذا بدا الغرب الجماعي في
استخدام اسلحه ذات مكون نووي لنقترب اكثر
من هذا المكون حيث تعرف لجنه التنظيم
النووي الامريكيه اليورانيوم المنظم بانه
الذي تقل فيه نسبه اليورانيوم 235 عن سبعه
اعشار في المئه من المئه يستخدم في تقويه
وتعزيز دروع الوقايه وتشمل تغطيه الفولاذ
باليورانيوم المنظم بكثافه تبلغ ضعفين
ونصف كثافه الفولاذ العادي ويستخدم هذا
النوع من الدروع مثلا في الدبابات
ومدرعه ام
[موسيقى]
اضافه الى السميه اليورانيوم من منظف اذا
تسرب الى التربه على مر السنين
[موسيقى]